in the quran at the end of surat yusuf
which allah says is the best of all
stories
allah says
that we tell you these stories so you
can derive lessons from it
and the reason we study malcolm x not
only is it
to understand the great contribution the
great legacy that he has
but also the lessons that we can take
from it because
in his autobiography when both of you
read it
you'll find many things which people
today
try to use to cancel him his views
on zionism his views on women
his views on the white race many things
which
are taken out of context in which we can
have a proper discussion on
but he understood life he understood it
at a very high level
and he was solely dedicated towards the
international muslim cause
[Music]
[Music]
first and foremost the prophet salallahu
he said that
basically when a group of companies came
to him and asked you know we're dealing
with these horrible
doubts you know these doubts that if we
believe them they would lead to kufur
horrible doubts and the prophet
salallahu he said that this is good news
this is good news and obviously it's
very it sounds
upsy moronic how is you know big doubts
in faith
good news in the prophet he said it's a
sign of high iman
and think about it if you have
catastrophic
life-changing doubts about your religion
it can't be anything other than a sign
that you have
high faith because you don't wake up in
the morning
and become worried that unicorns don't
exist
because you never believed in unicorns
in the first place so the fact that
these
doubts are worrying you is a sign that
you have high iman
that you actually believe in islam
dear brothers and sisters welcome back
to the t2m we are missing
the king of intimacy but that is all
right we are
gathered here today with brother ah man
i had done a a podcast with him in his
podcast what's your podcast called bro
it's just called the ahmed khan podcast
right now
masha'allah listen if you guys haven't
seen that one as soon as you're done
with this podcast we'll leave
a link in the description box you can
check out
his podcast specifically
but today my bro before we even get
started why don't you introduce yourself
to the audience
my name is ahmed khan so i am the
founder of the ahmed khan podcast
i currently have a history degree
a bachelor's degree in history with a
specialization within islamic history
and i am a research assistant at reclaim
which is an organized muslim
organization aimed at
working with school districts and
universities and institutions
on reforming their curriculums on islam
because we believe that
the core problem that we're kind of
dealing with here is education
and so much of my work involves my work
at reclaim
and asides from that i'm currently
enrolled in a program
to uh for studying islamic law and
theology
and so inshallah i'm doing a bachelor's
degree there as well um
related to our topic here uh related to
malcolm x i've published
uh a critically acclaimed article on my
website
at ahmed khan.ca titled mecca in malcolm
how mecca reached malcolm before he did
and it's a 21-page article which malcolm
x scholars have
uh acclaimed as something which is
unprecedented which doesn't exist
within our literature and so uh much of
our conversation today will touch upon
it
uh but and if anybody is interested in
learning more about
just the generic life of malcolm x may
allah be pleased with him
you can head to my channel uh ahmed khan
podcast
and you'll find a lecture i did at a
prominent university on his life
and also on his legacy um and
thank you guys for having me on it's
just gonna here for being on the level
[ __ ] say that again
your mic is it the sure mv7 you know
what bro you know
here we go bro real recognize real oh
that's cute
all right bismuth so before we go on i'm
assuming that none of our you know let's
just go and assuming none of our
audience knows who malcolm x is
right so go into that just give us like
basic brief
uh foundation
rubbish
before i begin i just want to quickly
say that
i'm not too interested here speaking
about the legacy of malcolm x
rahimahullah from the african-american
perspective
and the legacy that he's had upon that
community because i feel there's
um people more qualified but also
because
there's so many facets to his life that
we can discuss
and inshallah we will touch upon some of
them but for those who don't know uh
malcolm x born malcolm little
um was born during the before the civil
rights movement in america
and he grew up with crazy experiences
you know seeing the kkk
kill his father seeing white men take
his mother
uh away from them and putting her into a
mental asylum
in which she never recovered for and
because of the conditions within his
life
it ultimately led him to become
radicalized and so he became a drug
dealer
he became a pimp he became a criminal
and ultimately malcolm x ended up in
prison
and while he was in prison he began to
reevaluate his life
and he came upon the teachings of what
was called the nation of islam
the nation of islam is not orthodox
islam
but it's a different sect well i
wouldn't even call it sec it's just a
completely different religion
created by somebody named wallace d fard
who claimed that he was allah so this
individual knew the teachings of islam
and so he created this religion and he
created these temples
around the united states and it started
out very small
and so he came across a man named elijah
muhammad
who was an african-american man and told
them that he was now the prophet of god
and that he was god himself and so
wallace the fart ended up leaving
disappearing
and giving placing the hand of the
religion to elijah muhammad
and he began to create temples and
ultimately malcolm x's brothers
converted towards this religion
and that religion began to espouse
some teachings similar to islam but
people identified as a as kind of a
black nationalist
religion um and one of their core
beliefs was that
all white people with no exceptions all
white people are the devil
inherently and they have a whole
theology surrounding that
and so when malcolm x was in prison and
his brothers came to him
they convinced him of their religion and
he converted to it and the reason why it
was so appeasing to him
which people should really contemplate
on is they told him
that all white people are the devils and
so in his autobiography malcolm says
that when he began
to ponder upon that meaning he realized
that that statement was true
that every white person he ever met was
a devil
including the kkk who killed his father
including uh the security officers who
placed his mother into a mental asylum
including the teacher who told him that
he can't be a lawyer
and the best thing he could be was a
carpenter including the white woman who
deceived him
and including the white judge who
screwed him over
and so that's how he came in contact
with the nation of islam
and the beauty is when he came in
contact with this religion
is it opened his mind up and he finally
became what we now deem
woke and so he was reading every single
book that was out there
the toughest of books and subhanallah
you know
you know allah had given him guidance at
that time he was he was within the wrong
religion
but at that point he was dedicated to
the pursuit of knowledge
which our prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam has said from the cradle to the
grave
and so malcolm x understood that and he
spent
weeks writing every single word in a
dictionary
from the beginning until the end and
after he completed that he realized he
could now actually write sentences now
because his education was so poor
leading up to it
that he couldn't even write a sentence
and so ultimately he began to debate
and once he got outside of prison he
became a minister of the nation of islam
and that's where he became prominent
during the civil rights movement
and obviously we don't have enough time
to go through the entirety of it
but in 1959 and this is what my paper
argues
in 1959 malcolm is sent to saudi arabia
and he's sent to sudan and while he's
there he realizes that the islam
that he has been teaching is the wrong
islam
and so the sudanese including one man
named dr malik baduri
who is known today as the father of
modern islamic
psychology was working with him and
convincing him what orthodox islam is
and so when malcolm x comes back from in
1959 he realizes there's a contradiction
between the two religions
and now he sets on this journey trying
to figure out what true islam
is and a sudanese student named ahmed
usman comes to him
and tells him in while malcolm is
preaching in his own mosque
a sudanese man says to him he says
you're preaching the wrong islam
islam does not teach hatred based on a
person's skin color
and malcolm x malcolm x may allah be
pleased with him knew the quran very
well
and so he quoted a verse of the quran
which said that
the people with blue eyes on the day of
judgment will be in some sort of torment
and ahmed usman told him that's the
wrong interpretation
of that ayat and so they had a little
debate but they became friends
and malcolm told him i need you to give
me proper islamic darwah materials
because i i need to figure out what true
islam is
and so that relationship which lasts
about four or five years
ultimately ends up in 1964 of malcolm x
taking the shahada
in new york not while at hajj
in new york he took and we have the
physical document which shows
his signature that he became a muslim
and so
that's one of the major misconceptions
about him but malcolm x
when he goes on his famous hedge trip
his mind begins to open because he
begins to realize
that islam is the religion that solves
the race issue
because while he was there he was
sleeping with people who had white skin
color
and he said something quite fascinating
he said the white people over there were
white
not when they said they were white it
wasn't something they were necessarily
proud of
it wasn't a quality but it was just the
color of their skin
and they treated me just like i was any
other person as if we were
all one brotherhood and so when malcolm
x comes back he begins to preach
true islam but inevitably he gets into
conflicts with the nation of islam
and ultimately malcolm x is murdered
while giving a khutba and what's
something so interesting about malcolm x
subhan
subhanallah
is his career begins on the mimbar
and it also ended on the mimbar meaning
it began when he when he started giving
his khutbahs
and at that same spot the last words of
his life
were assalamu alaikum
and then he was shot six shotgun bullets
within the heart
immediately killed him but it's
important to remember
that at that moment that was the moment
that allah honored him
and how did allah honor him allah
honored him by giving him the title of
shaheed
of martyr and so that was the day
malcolm x was elevated
into one of the highest statuses that
any human being can receive
which is the level of martyrdom and so
in a nutshell that is the life of
malcolm x and
malcolm x rahimahullah is responsible
for the conversion
of thou hundreds of thousands if not
millions of people
and some of our biggest scholars here on
the west converted to islam because of
malcolm x
and today we're seeing particularly
within the nba we're seeing people like
stephen jackson
like kyrie irving like jalen brown and
i'm making a prediction right here
on the three muslims podcast and
inshallah works but kevin durant i
believe
is a secret muslim and i believe he will
come out as well
but all of them malcolm x played a
significant role
and without malcolm x i want everybody
to listen very
carefully without malcolm x we do not
get
muhammad ali we get muhammad ali the
boxer
but not muhammad ali the political icon
because malcolm was responsible for
ali's conversion
they were best friends and when nobody
was in muhammad ali's corner when he had
this big fight against sunny liston
the nation of islam did not want him
none of the reporters wanted him
he only had one man in his corner
metaphorically and literally
because he invited malcolm there and so
malcolm x has left a tremendous legacy
um
and installa through this discussion we
can get
more insight into who this brilliant
person was inshallah
so bro i have a question for you
just like hearing everything so far
why malcolm x like wha what brought you
to malcolm x where you started
researching and uh
basically you found out that he became
muslim before
going on hajj i just stole my question
oh that's what you're gonna ask as well
yeah because you know it's
passionate but i was wondering like why
him specifically
[Music]
in the page in malcolm x's autobiography
on the page before he goes to prison
he says people are always asking me how
i became the person that i became
and he said it's not a simple question
to answer because if you want the answer
you need to analyze a person's life from
the moment that they're born
up until this stage and once you've
analyzed everything
then you'll have an idea of how i became
the person that i became
and how i went from somebody who was a
drug dealer to a prisoner
into somebody who fight who found the
light and the religion of islam
which allah honored me with and so
that's
i'm paraphrasing but that's almost
directly what he says in his
autobiography
and you know you know in life you go
through different types of awakenings
there's one awakening which we call the
spiritual awakening
there's a time in our life where we wake
up spiritually
for for people like ang hell it's when
they come across the truth
and they realize that they found the
truth and now they want to live their
entire life
knowing that you know islam is what my
life is about it's what the purpose of
my life
is for those people who are born muslims
for them that awakening for some people
it doesn't happen
for other people there's a moment in a
person's life
where they go from being praying salah
because their parents have forced them
to
to them doing it on their own accord and
so that is one form of awakening but
in my life the intellectual awakening
one of the most
profound moments of my entire life which
completely
changed the entirety of my life was
reading the biography of malcolm x
and i remember that moment so vividly
because it was it was black history
month
and somebody had shared an article that
said the name malcolm x
and at that time i was like i've heard
of the name malcolm x before
and i've heard he had some relation with
islam
but i'm not sure necessarily what that
is
and so i remember watching a documentary
immediately
and after i finished it i said i need
more
it's like you know it's like you know
stuff little i don't like this
comparison but it's like when somebody's
hooked on something
whether it's like you know a drug or
something you know they need more of it
and i was like i was like yo i literally
tomorrow first thing in the morning i'm
going to the library
and i'm going to pick the fattest book
on malcolm x
um and so i went to the library and i
just picked up the first book that was
there
i didn't even like read the back cover i
just picked it up checked it out
and i i blazed through that book and
that
moment while i was reading it is what
changed the complete trajectory of my
life
subhanallah and so malcolm x is
one of the most profound characters
within my life
after allah allah's messenger
my immediate family i put him up there
and no matter how many books that i read
of his
there's always more to learn and the
least i can do to him is i can
explain to people his legacy for what he
has done for me
and so people who know me well they
always joke around
about me and malcolm x they'll always
create these memes
and stuff like that because of how much
i love him
and how much we as a community are
blessed to have somebody like that
and when he was in saudi arabia they
told him
saudi arabia or egypt they said we are
going to make you the imam of america
and that is our imam some people want to
discredit him
and say he had a very low understanding
of islam that's false
he went he studied at al-azhar
university he received ejazza
meaning a certificate he studied in
saudi arabia
and he began to understand his religion
at a
almost at a high level like he was
getting there
and he was our imam he established
masjids
here in uh in america and um
you know many people have given their
testimonies but
he's had a profound impact on my life
and that's why i personally feel that
if some when people come to me and this
happened just this week people come to
me and they say ahmed
how can we get woke or ahmed i'm
interested in reading
the first thing i always tell them is
the greatest book you'll ever read is
the quran
and i keep emphasizing that to them but
some of them they also say okay can you
give us another supplementary book
and judging by the person most of the
time i recommend the autobiography of
malcolm x
and wallahi you know i swear by allah
i've seen people's
lives change through that book complete
lives and
you go you know you can ask other people
other scholars
and they the great are some of our
biggest scholars in the united states
became muslim because of malcolm x
and i'll repeat that white converts
have become some of the biggest scholars
in the united states
people like dr omar farooq abdullah
simply because of reading malcolm x and
his story
and so um as deep as an attachment that
i have to him there are people who have
deeper attachments
but i've visited harlem um i've been to
the spots where he's done his khutbas
and i've been to the first masjid that
he created
and i've had conversations with some of
the brothers over there but
he is somebody who's legacy we're now
we're beginning to see
revived now the name malcolm x it's
almost a household name even though
people don't know
who he is and so this is this is
something that inshallah we should be
working on because
his philosophy matches identically
almost
with the three muslims podcast it's like
a perfect connection
man really how so well one thing is
malcolm was against feminine men
and much of your guys's work so for
example
um he knew that islam had specific
teachings
surrounding women and men and gender
relations
but he said one of the core problems is
that our men have become
weak and that we need to make our men
strong
and that's why part of the nation of
islam they have they had almost like
a security or like a military agency
underneath it called the fruit of islam
and it really made men tough and as much
as we kind of want to hate on the nation
of islam because their aqida is false
they've done a tremendous job one at
bringing people
uh into the falls of islam from the
african-american community
but they were very strong people and
that's where malcolm x gets
gets his strong nature people quote his
favorite saying
that be nice be courteous to people
but if somebody puts their hand on you
you send them to the grave
because this was a man who didn't mess
around and when people came to his house
near the end of his life to firebomb his
house
immediately he took his ak and he went
outside
and he said if i saw a single person out
there i would have started shooting
because he saw he saw that as a as a
test
as an attack on his family and he knew
he was the head of a family
and you know you have for example you
guys have your intimacy series and stuff
too
he said that the core characteristic
that women chase after
is not men that are that are kind but
it's men who are strong
men who can protect them and
these are some of the things that i've
taken from your podcast which i think
coincide with malcolm's philosophy
bro i'm gonna be honest with you i had
no idea it was like this with malcolm x
bro
like i heard about him in school but it
wasn't nothing like this it was like
oh uh you know malcolm x
something about uh black history month
and they
they kind of like said a little bit here
and there but i never read
his uh his biography that's what you
said right
autobiography written by him yeah my
apologies my apologies
no i think i might add that to my q now
inshallah yeah i'm gonna read that too
i'm gonna read that too inshallah
because bro
like he sounds legit
you know malcolm x is
one of the most eloquent speakers in
human history
and all you have to do is go on youtube
because most of his speeches are on
youtube
and just listen to the type of rhetoric
that he has
and it's the most it's so convincing
that even people who disagreed with him
recognized his eloquency and today when
you want to study rhetoric
you know people want to say rhetoric is
bad rhetoric is a means of
convincing people of beautifying your
language um
and uh the proof of why the quran is the
word of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala is not
necessarily scientific
but it's rhetorical and the stuff that
the quran
uh and allah subhanahu wa says so
rhetoric is something which is good
um touching upon your point why
people don't know more about him malcolm
x said rahimahullah in the last page of
his autobiography
because the last chapter of his
autobiography was one that was written
before his death in which he discussed
his death and what the world would think
about him after he died
i mean this is the wisdom that allah
gave him that he knew he was going to
die
and he knew that this last paragraph was
going to have a profound
impact on how his legacy was told
and i think you know in the third last
paragraph
i almost have the book like memorized
now
but on the last page he says that when i
die
the white man is going to convince you
that i was a demigod
that i was a hate preacher but all i was
doing
is i was revealing up i was holding up a
mirror
that's going to reflect back that was
that was reflecting the crimes
that the white race has done against my
people
and he said their media is going to
brainwash
people into thinking that i am this this
this hate preacher
and that's precisely what happened after
he passed away
and the school textbooks used to be
filled with that type of rhetoric
that's how the media used to perceive
him all of the biographies had that
but what you're witnessing now within
really like the last 10 years
among this whole black lives matter
movement is people are beginning to
reassess his legacy
and they're beginning to realize that
there's a lot of things that we thought
about him
are actually false especially this one
point that
he believed that all white people were
evil and that they should be
somewhat demonized when he was with the
nation in the early moments
because that was part of the nation's
teachings he did
necessarily believe in it but very early
on all the way
up to 1959 so five years before his
death
he began to disavow those beliefs and he
began to say it
in like at an archetypical level talking
about what the right race has done to my
people
and not necessarily what every white
person has done
and so there are books out now called
the sword and the shield
um the other one is called dreams and
nightmares and they revealed that
malcolm and dr king were a lot closer in
their philosophy
and they weren't necessarily always at
odds with one another
and in fact during the last uh month
or two of malcolm's life uh when he left
the nation
he visited uh dr king's wife because dr
king was in prison at that time and he
told her
this is very interesting he told her he
said he said the reason my views are so
radical
is that when the white man looks at me
he realizes how radical i am
and then he'll say that dr king's option
is a lot less radical
and we should just follow him instead
subhanallah so the mind games he was
playing
were he was at another level subhanallah
and
few people reached that level especially
he he died at the age of 39.
and remember the prophets begin at the
age of 40
because at 40 is when the wisdom comes
in the hikmah comes in
and when he was 38 39 you began to see a
change in his rhetoric
he's not as aggressive he's more calm
because he's really trying to figure out
what the answer is
and one of the most beautiful hallmarks
of malcolm x
rahimahullah which all of us should
aspire towards
is he was very sincere and he was
always checking to make sure whether or
not his beliefs were correct
or whether or not they were false and
that's the reason why he embraced
orthodox islam is that when ahmed usman
the sudanese student approached him
rather than saying get out of my mosque
you know what he said to him instead
he said i've been to sudan and i know
the sudanese. the sudanese have treated
me nicely and so we will treat him
nicely
and it was the sudanese muslims that
gave that impression on him
and all of the major muslims in his life
whether it was
ahmed usman whether it was malik bedari
or whether it was his sheikh i can't
remember his name they were all
sudanese and so we have a lot to thank
the sudanese for the legacy of malcolm x
rahimahullah
but the other thing of malcolm x which
is very important and people don't
discuss
because this is hard information to find
is that malcolm x
was somebody who was the furthest thing
from being a snitch
and when he left the nation of islam and
they had horrible relations with one
another
the fbi came to his house and this is
all on youtube
you can listen to the audio recording
and the fbi tells him
that now that you're away from the
nation we think the nation is radical
so if you can please give us some
information we'll give you some sort of
incentive
and the first thing he says to them
again it's on youtube
is there's no way i'm going to snitch on
my fellow african-american
there's no way don't don't be stupid
enough to think that i'm going to
compromise here for a couple dollars
and he didn't know he was being recorded
either
and the fbi had been monitoring malcolm
x
for the entirety of his career and
the man who was recording malcolm x hit
record
spying on his recordings spying on his
phone call
following him wherever he went he said
this is a man of high moral character
who does not smoke
nor does he drink and
they tried everything they possibly
could to find some sort of flaw within
malcolm
after his career began and they could
not find
anything which reveals how much he
valued his religion
and he knew islam and a very he knew at
least the quran at a very high level
he knew quranic verses he used to quote
hadith
he always used to say
that actions are based upon intentions
and he used to say
if the person had the intention of a
devil well that makes them the devil
so and the last thing i will say
regarding this topic is
um in 1961 elijah muhammad
got malcolm x and he said we're going to
meet with the kkk
and malcolm said are you sure about that
like
like these guys are trying to kill us
they're the ones that killed my father
and elijah muhammad said both of us have
similar goals
in that the kkk want their own state or
their own country without the african
americans
and we want our own country our own
state without the white population as
well
and so malcolm x had a meeting with the
kkk
in which the kkk came visiting him and
they had a discussion
and some of them were fbi informants and
that's really
how we have the story is because the fbi
infiltrated everything and also when
malcolm was killed
the people that were around him and i
think including the person who was
holding his body
they were all fbi informants
and there's a good book called the fbi
and religion
which has a chapter solely on malcolm x
and his relation with the fbi
and they used every tactic possible to
cause disunity between both of them
the same tactics they use in the post-9
11 world
where they try to go against the muslims
by sending fake converts there
is the same tactic they use against
malcolm x and so
malcolm x was a very smart individual
and he knew the fbi was always
monitoring him
so in that interview when both sides
were there
um the kkk said to malcolm
uh we can make you partners um
and uh malcolm x rhetorically he was
saying as a joke to them because he
wasn't scared of them he wasn't scared
of nobody
except allah he said what do you mean we
can't join the kkk
um as an official joke and uh they said
well you know maybe we can
make you a partner he said are you guys
gonna give us the white robes as well
and they said we can't give no black
person a white robe
and so he said um like we really want
one they're like we'll get you a purple
robe
and he said you know what like like
screw you guys like we don't want
anything to do with you guys um
and so they asked now that you disagree
with dr
king and you have issues with him
give us his address and we'll kill him
for you
and malcolm x responded and said there's
no way in hell
i'm going to give you his information
and there's no way in hell
even though i disagree with him then i'm
going to allow you to kill an
african-american
and the last another lesson we can take
from him
is you know throughout the quran allah
says talks about unity
hold tightly onto the rope of allah and
don't be divided
and although malcolm understood the
divisions that existed within his
african-american community particularly
his relations with the nation of islam
he never snitched on anybody and he
always wanted to make sure that there
was more unity
and so these are some of the lessons
that i think we can take from malcolm x
um but we can have entire series on
malcolm x
um because of the influence that he's
had and what lessons we can take from it
because
you know that's the story in the quran
at the end of surat yusuf
which allah says is the best of all
stories
allah says
that we tell you these stories so you
can derive lessons from it and the
reason we study malcolm x not only is it
to understand the great contribution the
great legacy that he has
but also the lessons that we can take
from it because in his autobiography
when both of you read it you'll find
many things which people
today try to use to cancel him his views
on zionism his views on women
his views on the white race many things
which are taken
out of context in which we can have a
proper discussion on
but he understood he understood
life he understood it at a very high
level
and he was solely dedicated towards the
international muslim cause
and when he was in egypt he wrote an
article for them
refuting zionism and talking about how
the palestinians were being mistreated
and what he said is that if the argument
is that
the jews were there first he said well
the muslims were in spain first
does that give muslims the right to go
into spain today and kick out the
spanish
population showing you know he was
showing the flaws within their argument
and he was the first one to speak out
against vietnam
and the oppression and the war that was
going on there so he spoke about
everything because he understood that
justice
is what we are after and he has a famous
saying which
is very hard to find but i came across
he said i would never follow a religion
which told me to only pray and not do
anything else about it
today we hear often just make dua and
things will get better even though the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
that tie your camel and ask for the dua
and make dua to allah subhanahu wa so
that's you know in a nutshell that's who
malcolm x may allah be pleased with him
is
what were his views on women
yeah well he believed in the traditional
islamic understanding of gender roles
so i'll give you an example my last
semester at university um i took a class
on
malcolm x and dr king and
we were reading you know there are some
of the books on malcolm x you have to be
careful about
because people have all these ideologies
so for example you have some
manning maribel is one of the most
famous he tries to make a
very ignorant argument that malcolm x
during his criminal days was a
homosexual
he has no evidence for it at all and my
response to him
is when malcolm became a criminal he i
mean when malcolm became a preacher
he continuously talked about all of the
sins that he engaged in
and had he engaged in that homosexual ad
he would have told us
because that would have only increased
the legacy
um the power that islam had on him so
it's a very stupid argument
the other argument to try making is oh
he was a misogynist
why well because he believed in you know
what what today is called the patriarchy
right which you guys have you know you
guys know very well he believed in
you know men woman the man was the head
of a family
and just like he criticized men he
criticized women
because both genders are open to
criticism
and so when he did that some people said
oh you know he's he's a bit misogynistic
but
that was furthest from the case his wife
loved him
there's no instance of him ever hitting
her uh
these things just don't exist so you
know they want to come after our heroes
at the end of the day and if we're not
publishing uh articles academically
refuting them
this is what the masses are going to be
taught and so when i was in that class
i was just bodying everyone subhanallah
like i i was just so
passionate that anytime they brought up
any of these accusations
i just had to put even the professor
into her place
um even though she loved me but uh we
have to honor our great heroes
and he is one of our great imams that
lived
you know he lived when you know our
parents our grandparents were alive
he's not that old right he's still
around
and so that's basically his views on
woman same thing as islam
[Music]
all right so
when you were saying about the things
the awakenings and you know we were
referring how i had my awakening when i
came across
the truth the quran uh you were saying
about the awakenings how some born
muslims have when they
actually start to practice the deen
without being told
to do so and then you had mentioned the
intellectual awakening
that you had when you had picked up this
book and you started reading about
malcolm x so my question is that
what what exactly was this awakening for
you like
what popped in your head that like
you would even refer to as an awakening
just give me one second i need to close
my door and i'll answer your question
making too much noise go ahead bro
i just want to make a quick note that
when brother ahmed mentioned that
um you know that's 40 is when you know
all the prophets
uh you know people men became prophets
right it's all of the
the prophets except uh islam islam but
i'm sure you all know that if you know
what you should know yeah yeah
so that's an excellent question bro um
you know in in life i'm gonna be mention
this again
because it's relevant you go through
these awakenings
um and when you go and i'm sure
you know both of you have been through
it so you can relate but when you go
through these awakenings
you really begin to see life through a
completely different lens
and you begin to really question you
don't really question your existence
in like a nihilistic way but you're
really just questioning like
what have i been really been doing my
whole life
like i've been really wasting the
entirety of my life and that's really
how i felt
and when i picked up that book and i
finished it
i knew from that moment my life had
changed
and a new door a new chapter was going
to open
and at that time i was not i was not
a properly practicing muslim in the
sense that i was praying but again
my parents were kind of forcing me and
so that coincided with kind of my
religious
my spiritual awakening and it all came
together and just
i had that i had that thing that i was
really searching for
right you know we all we all of us you
know there's a point of our life where
we've been watching motivational videos
on youtube
right motivation in this fyad knows
because he's a trainer
um but you watch these motivational
videos
because you're always lazy and for some
people they watch it because they really
want to work out
for other people it's because they want
to study for other people they really
just want to
transform their life and what always
happens when you watch that video
is you get a high that doesn't last long
and so you're stuck on the cycle of
continuously watching these videos
over and over again and it's the same
cycle
and so for me i used to binge watch all
those videos
but nothing would change but the moment
i started reading
i began to realize that this is the
motivation
that i need and that's why the first
word that allah revealed in the quran
was not listen was not speak
was not go out and do other things but
it was
read read because readers
are leaders readers are the ones who are
who are having an impact on this world
the people at the highest level
intellectually were readers and malcolm
x said that when he was in prison
you could not find one moment
where he was not reading and because he
was such a good student
they allowed him to take the library
books into his room
and i want everybody to listen to what
listen to this because this perfectly
encapsulates how much malcolm x value
knowledge
at the end at night time at the end of
every hour
an officer would walk through the halls
to make sure everybody was asleep
and what malcolm x would do is he would
read
all night long and every time the hour
would begin
as the officer would walk by he would go
to bed
and he would fake sleep and because the
only light was the light in the hallway
after the officer left he would go all
the way into the
into the prison walls and he would be
reading there
and he read so much that he says in his
autobiography
i went from having 20 20 vision to
getting glasses
just because of his addiction for
reading and
you do not get malcolm x without reading
you simply do not malcolm x did not
watch videos
he didn't attend lectures he did he did
these things
he debated but reading because reading
was the foundational thing
that opened up the entirety of his life
and he had read the great works of
history
malcolm x was a historian he was a world
he knew philosophy he knew philosophy at
a very high level he had read all the
great works
he had wrote read the books on genetics
and most importantly he understood the
crimes
that the white race had done to his
people
and when he when he would read them he
would begin to cry
and but despite all of that he always
read about islam
he read many of the da'wah books even
while he was in prison he used to read
books in islam
and again this is something very few
people knew
but alchemics when he wanted to study
christianity
when he was in prison because he was
very sincere
he got he got he didn't bring
a chaplain
jehovah's witness person said and they
want to hide all this information
oh i'm cutting out yeah you're cutting
out brother here we go
all right one sec second
okay can you hear me keep it in that was
perfect that's perfect
it sounded like a like you know when you
like speak into a fan like a
physical fan and then i and then hear
jehovah's witnesses and i was like what
but readers are leaders bro i like that
quote bro it sounds like some something
i'd seen in the library
when i was a kid 100
um and so what the jehovah's witness
person said
is as much as i was teaching him about
islam i mean uh
um the jehovah's witness said as much as
i was teaching him about christianity
he had a very particular interest in
islam
and he wasn't referring to the nation of
islam he was referring to orthodox sunni
islam
and you will find people who if you
won't believe this you'll find this in
the book
on the side of my people a religious
biography of malcolm x
by luis de caro you know you always
gotta have your preferences ready
because people
will always accuse you um and so
malcolm x even when he was in prison he
was reading biographies of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and this is a fact and so um
readers are leaders man readers are
leaders and in our community we're
trying to get book club started
and um you know i'm trying to also do it
with my own podcast have my own personal
book club and open up to people
but it also would be beneficial if the
three muslims kind of did their own
because um you see many people many of
our big scholars are big academics
they have their own book clubs and
they're able to teach people these
things
and interestingly one of the first books
they read
is the autobiography of malcolm x
subhanallah
and so um our community needs to be
readers
this is the statistics are very clear
the nations that are doing the best
per capita are the nations that are
doing the best are the ones who are
reading the most books per capita
and so reading is really what we should
be striving for any in today's age bro
if you don't really have the time to sit
down and read that's fine
we have audio books and audio books are
one of the greatest inventions of the
last 10 years
in my life because while i'm working out
while i'm going for a jog while i'm
driving eating food i'm finishing a book
and in the span of time that i could be
instead listening to music
or i could be doing other things i'm
finishing a whole book
and i'm
no no but what i was saying is there's
some books though that you have to
physically read
that an audio book is just not going to
work
because the quran says
do they not ponder do they not deeply
reflect on the quran
or is it that they have locks on their
hearts and so when we're reading
we need to be contemplating very deeply
and some of this material
will only make sense the second or third
time that you're reading
and what my podcast is really about is
i'm just doing
a lot of it of what i'm doing are book
reviews with authors
because i'm trying to condense the
entire book its entire thesis
in the span of one hour and so readers
are leaders
and fayad do something with that like
with that line bro
100 100 you know
when you were saying read it reminds me
of the uh
the
spoken word by um
i think it's like one islam or islam
path or something like that have you
guys seen that the meaning of life
uh but i think it's by jabir jaber
ibrahim is i think his name
and his relative his uncle or relative
is the one who did the janazah from
malcolm x i believe
subhanallah really yeah i believe his
name is
ibrahim and his his one of his relatives
did the janaza for malcolm x from if
from whatever calls from hanover so it's
all connected bro
it's all connected
so another question man
because i'm like i'm curious i like
knowing like what's
actually popping off in someone's mind
in someone's
life when they have this type of
awakening but you said
that it was like this motivation for you
was like deeper than motivation it's
like
when you read it it's like you knew
something was gonna change
but what was it specifically that stood
out
if it wasn't the entire book like it was
like something specific that just really
popped off at you
it's hard to pinpoint one specific thing
even though i can give you many but the
thing about malcolm x's life
rahimahullah is that his life
reveals and i know this is going to hit
home with everybody but especially with
angel
is the story of malcolm x's life
is it's not about how you start the race
it's about how you end the race and it
doesn't matter
if you grew up in a muslim family just
because of that you're not guaranteed
paradise
because people lose their faith some
people question the religion and on the
other hand
you have people who are not born into
muslim families and end up finding it
and had we judged and the story is you
can't judge people until you know the
ending of their life
because if we judge malcolm based on
when he was in prison
all of us collectively would have said
some horrible things about him which i
don't want to say
but because you see the end you see
where he ended up
and really all of malcolm x's work that
he does within his career
is a span of 17 18 years it's very short
very short it's not that long but after
he had that awakening
what i resonated with is he saw the
problems in his community in the
african-american community
and he said we need to do something
about this
and the one thing i think the
islamophobia industry
is because they woke me up on this topic
because
i started reading their material and
saying if this is what they're saying is
islam really true
and so i started studying islam at a
deep level reading through thick
research articles and then i began to
realize like look i need to be proud
that i'm a muslim
and i know you guys have i think a video
or like a short clip you posted on
youtube
about how you know you we weren't always
the most practicing muslims
and the islamophobia industry is
responsible for me for
having that awakening but that comes
after malcolm x
and so my message to everybody who is
who is going through
moments in their life where they need
motivation
where they feel like they're not where
they're where they're at right now
and they're nowhere near their goal is
read and the most profound book you will
read
is the book of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and wallahi i swear
you combine all of the books here it's
nothing
compared to what the quran has done to
me i will say it
again and again some people want to say
that this is just
oh these people just hyping up their own
book no
the quran is the book ask angel what the
quran did to him
everybody the quran is the most profound
and in terms of being
woke the quran is the most the book that
will get you more woke than anything
because it explains to you
what this world is really about who
created the world
and why that person created you
and malcolm x did all of his secular
reading i don't like using the word
secular
but he did all his secular reading but
when he came across the truth of islam
and he combined the two
that's when you got malcolm x
or what he called malcolm shabazz
because the x in his name is a
signification
of him eradicating his last name which
is the last name of his slave master
because his name is malcolm little and
what the nation of islam did
is they said we want to disavow our
our last names because these are white
men names there was no black man named
washington
right there was no black man named
little these are white names
and so we're going to remove it and
we're creating a new identity
and x represented the unknown the roman
numeral the unknown
and so malcolm x means malcolm and i
don't know my last name
and i don't want to be affiliated with
what my slave master name was
and ultimately he ended up taking the
last name shabazz
what's up well i'm about to change my
last name i'm hit
x
i'm just playing give me one second let
me let me get some light popping because
it's about to get real dark in here
tell me a little bit about why most
people think
um that the standard narrative is true
where he
became muslim or took a shahada um
during hajj or after hajj
malcolm x was a visionary
he could see into the future not in a
literal sense
but he could see how things would end up
and he knew how the media would
create this legacy about who he was and
how he hated white people
and that was the only thing he was a
hate monger he never preached hate
ever in his life he never called for
violence you cannot find a single quote
where he talks about violence it's all
about self-defense
self-defense is who malcolm was um
but because he was a visionary he knew
that he needed to do some da'wah
and he knew that his book was going to
become his legacy
and he actually says in his
autobiography he says that i could spend
a couple hours
working on this book and it would just
move the hearts a little bit
he said or i could spend years on this
book
and you could have a transformative
effect upon everybody
and so what he does in that book is
he intentionally you know at least
that's what i believe
and i have a lot of evidence to back
that up is he creates this narrative
that his shahada was during hajj
because he wanted to create the
impression of how beautiful islam was
and this by no means
is a way to diminish the impact that
hajj had on him
it had a completely transformative
effect on him
completely transformed him but he knew
that if he kind of carved it in this
manner
people would give the credit to islam i
mean they would give the credit to hajj
they would obviously give it to islam
but they would give it to hajj and they
would develop that level of curiosity
but if anybody is curious if anybody
thinks i'm wrong
i'm open to criticisms but please go on
my website ahmed khan ahmed
khan.ca and it's the first article
you'll see
mecca in i have all the references there
um and if you go on the about me page
you'll find my email you can correspond
with me
but many malcolm x scholars have
concurred with me
and there's documentaries on this and i
think that's where i think
we can kind of almost end off is
my uh
[Laughter]
guys my uh
my tripod is uh finito
noise bro my bad no worries
but um the best documentary on this
which
just came out this year is called um
it's on the youtube channel i think it's
called
history or islam films very prominent
i l m and then it's f i l m s
i'll send it to fayad and then he can
link in the description
but it's literally talking about
everything that i've said it's an
hour an hour and a half long and he
proves it as well so
you begin you'll see inshallah within
the next coming years
things are going to change about the
narrative and that's what people need to
understand
i did my degree in history we learn in
history that history is always changing
what we think of the past is not
necessarily what the past is it's our
understanding of the past
based on our limited set of observations
our limited set of evidence
and i make that very clear in my paper
that look if new evidence comes in
i'll change my complete thesis but as of
now i've
been through all of the academic
literature and this is where i've
ended up and the evidence there's
another documentary called
malcolm x and the sudanese and in the
documentary they literally hold up the
paper of malcolm x's jahada
like they're literally holding it up of
his testimony so
um inshallah you will see and this
podcast inshallah
will change many people's perceptions um
on the matter but um we kind of want the
right people speaking on
on behalf of malcolm x and people
speaking on the right components
which is why i'm a bit i'm a bit
hesitant to speak on the
african-american component of it
um bro so of defense yeah 100 have read
a bit but
self-discipline too that's one of the
main takeaways that i took from malcolm
x
i think in when he was in prison he had
like one meal a day right
he had one meal a day like uh throughout
his whole life
after prison the nation of islam said we
need to make sure our people
are strong physically and they
understood the importance of fasting and
there's a hadith
there's a hadith that says um i'm
paraphrasing
but the sahaba asked the prophet
salallahu
of a person who s one meal a day and the
prophet salallahu said this person is
among the prophets
the mba and then he said what about a
person who eats two meals a day
and the prophet salallahu said he's
among the righteous people and they said
what about a person who eats three meals
a day
and he says he's from like the low
people like he's from the lower class
although the nation didn't know that
hadith they were they knew the
importance of eating healthy so
so malcolm was skinny but he was a very
healthy individual
and because he was fasting he had a very
short mind
and our studies today prove that if you
want to have a sharp mind if you want if
you have like a test the next day you
should fast
and these are things we've known for
thousands of years in which
all of the prophets have been teaching
man so
do you ever get flamed for the fact that
uh
you you go so into this whole malcolm x
thing in his life
and do you ever do people ever say like
oh you uh
are you treating this guy like a prophet
or you're treating him like a
like an idol or something like that like
some [ __ ]
yeah like some shirky stuff do you ever
get flamed for that no
no i haven't you know i'd say something
funny so at our msa
um i did a lecture on malcolm x
and again you can find it on my youtube
channel um
and so the the the student body that was
booking the rooms
they saw that when we booked the room we
said malcolm x
like this is what we're going to talk
about and she later i spoke to her she
said
you know we were a bit scared because we
thought you were going to do some
revolutionary tactics in there
because malcolm is like he's like the
icon of social justice now
and again because people have the wrong
perception of him
which is changing alhamdulillah um
they're a bit like
they're a little bit scared and they
still have these old preconceived
notions which are being challenged today
and something very important for people
to understand very important
is when it comes to changing public uh
public opinion at the societal level
it's not the influencers who are going
to do it
it's not the influencers it's not the
media it's the people on top
which are the academics and so you have
a handful of academics together
who have conferences who talk on the
subject and when they declare a winner
they show that winner to the media they
show that winner to the media to the
influencers and because nobody can beat
these people
that's what public opinion now becomes
and now within public
opinion all of the books are portraying
malcolm x rahimahullah in a positive
manner subhanallah and this is
this is allah vindicating him from all
of the hate
that the people previously had upon him
and so
you will see a change even though it's
already happened now within these next
few years
people are going to lose these ideas and
it's already being taught
within the curriculums uh in the united
states and many of our scholars abroad
and this is another important thing is
that malcolm was known internationally
he was known when he died the newspaper
in pakistan
wrote an obituary about him the
newspaper in nigeria
wrote about him he had a massive
influence in indonesia in malaysia
a massive influence in turkey and many
turkish politicians write biographies of
him today
many people in europe in canada and
people within africa
see him as the model so he's somebody
who's international he's not only
focused in harlem he's not only focused
in america but he's gone
international and he is a role model for
all of us a man who did not compromise
his beliefs
who when he was offered many different
things
to just compromise on his beliefs he
said no and that's what the prophets do
the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam all the prophets they
don't compromise their beliefs
they never in spite of what the media
says in spite of what the cancer culture
says
they don't and malcolm x i believe
cannot really exist in today's age
in the sense of cancer culture because
they would have canceled him for saying
these things
and if somebody tries to speak like
malcolm x today
they won't be allowed at the
universities because universities are
very
careful especially student bodies of who
they invite but he spoke at all the
major
universities across the world and i
suggest everybody
to watch malcolm's lecture at oxford
university
it's on youtube and you just you see the
eloquence of this man subhanallah
so i get the feeling that uh malcolm x
was one of those
individuals where it's like you either
love them i hate them
there's no in between 100
man's holding like a selfie queen i am
i'm holding it
more than with two hands broken my
shoulders are tired
there we go bro get those angles
because i think it's i think it's hella
important bro i think it's hella
important that
this love me or hate me thing if you're
doing it for the sake of allah and his
messenger sallallahu salaam and you're
doing it for islam and you're speaking
the truth
it doesn't matter what people say um
hundred percent 100 percent if you made
it this far comment down below hashtag
bring ahmed back
and you can't be a real the three muslim
supporter
without going over and subscribing to
his channel right now a hundred percent
come on man where your mind works
subhanallah if you guys are on apple
podcast spotify you're missing out
because you can't see the
beautiful library behind them awesome
you know i was talking to ankel on my
podcast
and i was telling him that when it comes
to books we need to read quality over
quantity
and this man looks me in the eye and he
says you're really going to say that
with that massive library behind you
[Laughter]
mashallah what was the
other topic that we were we were
contemplating on discussing it was uh
between malcolm x
and i think it was jinns so there
there's a lot
of topics which inshallah i'm gonna do
my own podcasts on but i would love to
do with you guys as well
um many topics which are not explored
which need to be explored
um the jin evil eye one is a very big
one
because i have many muslims messaging me
muslims
muslims saying i'm questioning my faith
because of i can't believe in jinns an
evil eye
and then you have non-muslims who are
saying i'm interested in islam
but the thing that's holding me back is
jinns and evil eye so i've done
alhamdulillah a lot of research
on that that was the one topic we really
wanted to do because
there's a lot of information out there
there's more information that proves
that realm
than information that disproves it
and it's not even it's and people like
myself who've experienced that realm
who've come into contact with some of
these things and who have the stories
that they're willing to share
uh you know i was with a couple friends
uh two days ago
and i explained them a story an incident
i had with evil eye
and their jaws dropped and they were in
absolute shock because these things
exist
and i'm willing to share these stories
as well so that was one of the topics we
wanted to do
let's do that for the next episode then
yeah yeah yeah
i got some i got some off-camera
questions bro but uh let's wrap this up
yeah but with that being said
if y'all made it this far for the real
oh geez
i don't know what else to say but
assalamu alaikum
what better care too
much
came to him and asked you know we're
dealing with these horrible doubts
you know these doubts that if we believe
them they would lead to
horrible doubts and the prophet
salallahu he said that this is good news
this is good news and obviously it's
very it sounds
upsy moronic how is you know big doubts
in faith good news
in the process of he said it's a sign of
high iman and think about it
if you have catastrophic life-changing
doubts
about your religion it can't be anything
other than a sign that you have
high faith because you don't wake up in
the morning
and become worried that unicorns don't
exist
because you never believed in unicorns
in the first place so the fact that
these
doubts are worrying you is a sign that
you have high iman
that you actually believe in islam
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
hmm